welcome everyone this talk is about
seeing of programs do seeing how they
execute really seeing what happens
inside of them and I will begin by
explaining what I really mean by that
and after that we will look at a
practical example there will be some
live coding so I hope you can see it in
in the back if not please come forward
and I really want to show how easy it is
to make simple tools that are allow us
to look inside of programs and then we
will look at how to skill these
techniques to performance intensive
programs and larger programs and I will
conclude with an actual practical tool
that I've been working on for the last
couple of months or so to actually try
to use this in a production code base
but so what do I mean by this seeing
well when developing for the browser
some parts of writing a program are
already really official right you can
open your developer tools and you can
see the structure of the HTML you can
really look at how the page is
structured you can start changing CSS
values and see the effects of this
immediately
it's all very visible even though this
is not really something that the end
user would do but it's really useful to
us as developers but when doing web
development we also have JavaScript
right and we don't really have the same
the same introspection capabilities for
JavaScript we have all these objects and
variables and values and callbacks and
we can look at the code we can see how
the code is structured but we don't
really see what's going on once we start
running the program it just does
something but we can't really see what's
going on inside and we can take these
little Peaks into our system right so
for example we can maybe look at some
the network tab and see some requests
that we make and how to serve a response
and so on and maybe we can open the
console right and start calling some
some functions and we can sort of take
this peek into the system
trying to see what happens if if we call
a function what it returns and so on and
maybe we can we can set a breakpoint
somewhere right we can use the debugger
and pause the program at a certain point
in time step through it's it's it's very
local but it gives you some insight in
what's happening right there but we
don't really get an overview of
everything that's happening really a
real insight into into how our program
executes so you might wonder why would
we why would we want to do that right
why do we need all these silly graphics
or visualizations in order to write good
codes well one reason I think that there
are various reasons but the most obvious
one I think is debugging because when
you have a bug in your program something
is happening in your program that is
different than what you imagined it
would do right so you have a
representation of the program in your
head and the actual program is doing
something different and the only way to
resolve this is to get data from the
program into your head somehow and see
where this where this difference is and
for this we need to we do to do this in
the most efficient way possible right we
need some sort of some sort of user
interface some sort of visualization
that our eyes can see and that our brain
can easily parse so that we can
understand how our program works quickly
so how do we do this today well using
often using like print statements or in
the browser console log right we insert
them in our program to see what's going
on what the values of variables are at
different points in time
which parts of the program are being
reached in what order but that's a lot
of work so what what do we need to do
right first we need to be able to
reproduce the problem right and then we
come up with some sort of hypothesis of
why the program is doing what it's doing
why it is wrong and once we have this
hypothesis we need to get the data to
actually verify this hypothesis and we
add console.log statements and this is
called instrumentation
right adding measuring instruments to
our program and then we trigger the
error again so that we actually run the
program and we get back some data and in
the data there are some clues right so
maybe it does what you expected and you
have to form in another hypothesis or
maybe as some something is wrong but you
still don't know quite what it is and so
often you have to go back from a new
hypothesis instrument the program again
triggered er again look at the data
again and so this is a very long
feedback cycle until at some point
you're finding you can fix your bug but
why do we need to do this in the first
place it is not like we're trying to
understand some sort of complex physical
system we're setting up an experiment is
really hard right where we have to
control all the variables and make sure
that we measure very precisely come up
with a good formal hypothesis all that
stuff and everything that the program is
doing is happening in this computer that
we have here all the values all the data
that we could possibly care about it's
all going through the memory and the
processor at some point in time right so
why can't we just know all this stuff it
is it is our system like we are the
goths
we should be omniscient and the
technique that I'm going to talk about
today is actually called omniscient
debugging and it means that everything
is always locked and this giant log is
called an execution trace and it
contains all the data that you could
possibly want in order to understand how
the program works and you can saw my
facial eyes this so how does debugging
work with this well first of all we
don't have to instrument things
ourselves right because everything is
always locked and since we don't have
two instruments every time we come up
with the new hypothesis we can just run
the program once and we get all the data
so we don't need to retract the error
all the time and if you have a really
good omniscient debugging system you
even don't need to reproduce the problem
in the first place because you can just
download the execution trace from the
clients on which it happens right so
you're really left with with the real
problem solving tasks looking at
forming hypotheses and looking at the
data and I think that with the right
visualization this can happen happen in
a very short feedback loop while you're
looking at the data your brain can scan
it's trying to find patterns looking for
anything out of the ordinary so that's
sort of the theory behind it but let's
actually write some codes right so the
main points that I want to make today is
how easy all of this stuff is so I'm
just going to use JavaScript as an
example this might be like some silly
loop deep down in a larger application
it's very contrived but I will show you
how to do this for actual applications
later right so we have this this
visualization where after each variable
declaration yet this little spark line
of how it changes over time right very
simple and I'm not going to show you how
to actually draw lines I'm using react
with SVG in this case but I'm going to
show you how to actually get the data to
draw those lines right so that's what
we're going to do the way that we're
going to do that is we're going to
transform the program into another
program that has all this
instrumentation adults so instead of
adding console.log commands ourselves
ourselves we we use the computer to do
that let me show you what that looks
like I have some built-in commands that
we first print the program itself so I
can do lock left or forget program and I
just have the program as a string here
and I'm going to use a library called
falafel it's pretty old but it's really
simple to use and what it does is it
will parse the program and it will walk
the abstract syntax tree and you can you
can you can transform any note in the
program so this is what that looks like
so I call falafel on this thing with
some walk function now I need to find a
walk function and it takes some note and
then I just need to serialize this back
to a string and now we have our original
program again but this walk function
gets called and we can see what it does
so I can do something like this right so
here are all the notes types that were
walking over the first one is an
identifier
this letter a here and we have a literal
that's this number one variable
declaration that's this whole thing here
variable declaration that's the entire
line and the identifier here is this eye
again and so on and so forth so what we
want to do is every time we see a
variable declaration
we also wants to initialize a tracking
variable in the same scope that we can
use to track how the variable changes
over time right so I'm just literally
going to do that I'm going to say okay
whenever we have a note of type variable
declaration
and we're going to update that note and
change it right if I just do this you
see that they actually disappear so I
need to put in the original source again
like this but now I can add some sort of
suffix right so what are we going to put
in this suffix all we wants to
initialize this tracking variable and
I'm going to prefix it with log and then
the name of the original variable so I
can do notes of ID dot name so now I
have a log a and a log I here and what
are we going to initialize our tracking
variable with well we want some sort of
object here right with the line number
and an array of values so let's just
let's just do that here so I can add a
line number here and I need to add
something for that I can say the notes
of location don't start line and then I
also need to tell falafels to actually
check those line numbers and I do that
like this and now we have our line
numbers here and so the next thing is to
initialize this array of values right so
let's let's also do that so what are we
going to say here well we want some
values array and we actually can
initialize it with its initial value
already right because a has been
declared here and is been declared here
so I can just plug in this notify D dot
name here and here we have our initial
initial values array initialized make
sense so far well then what to do now is
I want to gather these these objection
through this big array and for that I'm
going to
to prefix the program that we get here
with with some with some string so I'm
going to call this program and actually
let me do this
I can add some string in front of it
right and so I'm going to add a a window
dots log which is just an array and then
I'm going to create a helper function
which I'm going to call start logging
and it just takes an object and it
pushes this object onto windows lock and
then it returns it right and now what we
can do is we can just wrap all of our
objects that we create here into the
start logging function and now since it
returns to function it returns the
objects like the original behavior of
assigning it to these tracking variables
is still there but we also add a
reference to the global log sorry oh
sorry
thank you we would have found out that's
soon that this is much better
so now we can actually run the program
right so I can call safe FL safe you
fellas just a regular FL only it makes
sure that like that book doesn't crash
if I make a mistake
and now we can actually see what this
window log looks like right so I can do
block right of window dot log and their
stuff in there great and we can actually
already plug this into this render
sparklines function right right just
move this down let this window log in
there and we already have a very basic
version of of this stuff all right so
the line numbers change if I move this
if I change this initial variable it
will change I can even add a string here
right because my visualization supports
that right so the only thing that's left
to do is actually keeping track of and
whenever a variable changes so how do we
do that let's look at the genotypes
again right so here we change the
variable and here we change one and
those are actually both assignment
expressions so here in both cases we
have an assignment expression and we can
just do the same thing as before right
so we can say okay well if we have a
note of type assignment expression let's
update it with the original node source
and some sort of suffix let's stop
evaluating for a second here otherwise I
get a little errors and let's look at
the program all right so now I have some
sort of suffix here after each
assignment assignment expression so what
do we put here well we want to access
our tracking variable again which is
prefixed with log and then in this case
it's node stuff left but name I believe
yep
and and we want to do something with it
well we want to we want to access the
values array and we want to push
something to it what do we want to push
to it well just a note that left would
name again right because it has just
updated so we push it to it and this is
pretty much it right so I can evaluate
my program again and now I have working
for clients and so let's just play a
little bit with this right like see what
happens if I do this right what what
happens if I change this what happens if
I remove the minus sign just think about
it for a second all right
and since my since my visualization
supports drinks as well I can also do
something like this
and this is actually interesting already
right because the way that I that I drop
these dots here is that the the y axis
the y coordinate is determined by the
length of the string and if you if you
notice there's like this little jump
here right because here we are adding
the same the same number of characters
to the string but here we're adding a
different number of characters and so
your brain can immediately spot patterns
like this right and so I would imagine
that even even for more complicated
things like objects or so but we could
invent some sort of representation and a
visual representation of it even though
it doesn't necessarily have to make a
lot of sense always how it is
represented as long as you can recognize
certain patterns in it it's easier to
spot anomalies this is just one
visualization right there visualizations
out there that actually seem to help you
find problems much faster and some
estimates say that's about half of a
programmers time is spent debugging so
making this just this easier would
already have a pretty big impact and I
think that visualizations like this are
not just useful for debugging but for
writing new code too yeah so now you
might think you know this is like a nice
small example but how does this how does
this impact my actual production
application like especially if you have
something very performance intensive all
this added instrumentation you know it
does it does add a lot of overheads to
running your program and this execution
trace a queue gets might be might be
huge so it might take a lot of memory
and and these are good points but they
can be solved and I will I will show you
now a project that I worked on not too
long ago now this is an educational
programming course and I wanted kids to
be able to make their own games which
they really like but having great
editing environments to do so right to
really immerse them in this editing
environment where they can understand
how programming works and how the
program executes so for this I had to
implement some tricks to fix this
problem of performance because even a
simple game like this is already
relatively performance intensive so let
me first show you what what this entire
environment can do so that you have a
sense of of the issues so let me just
refresh this to see if I can get this
right now there we go so first of all
you can you can just change stuff here
and it automatically like all three
large writes that's this is not the
official ization yet but it is also kind
of important in order to be able to do
things like this
well this visualization though is is
possible right and so you pass the probe
where program you can go back in time
and so here we're already looking at
previous states that the program had we
can inspect any one of these states and
see for example where this ball is being
drawn where these bricks are being drawn
what this function draws well all the
bricks I can move my mouse over over
this this one here and get a an
abstraction over time all these all
these ideas are taken from from previous
work so I can yeah I can do all these
things and then I also have a sort of
rough you into the execution trace at
the bottom here so if I move my mouse
over here I can really see step by step
what the program is doing each
statements but also like intermediate
expressions because you see exactly
what's going on so how does this work
well first a paddle is being drawn here
and maybe at some points is the ball and
then we are redrawing all the output
breaks right so now I kind of know how
this program works it might it might be
very efficient to like redraw all the
breaks all the time but that that's very
easy to spot this way so how do you make
something like this efficient right and
the trick is that if I just press play
again that the official stations go away
so while the program is running
oftentimes you don't need to see all
this information because so much is
changing so fast anyway so in theory we
could now be running our original
program without all the instrumentation
but how do we get stuff the how do we
get all the visualizations when when we
press pass that trick is in in two parts
snapshotting and deterministic replay
those might be familiar topics at this
conference so how this works is every
once in a while the system takes a
snapshot or checkpoint I've also heard
it called of the entire system
right so it's stored it makes a copy of
all the variables in memories all the
objects and it takes a copy of the of
the canvas here but it only does that
once in a while like it doesn't take
that much space or degrades performance
that much at least not as with a full
and the full execution trace and then
when we pause the program we just go
back to an earlier snapshot and we rerun
the program but this time with all the
instrumentation and the only way that we
can do this is if we make sure that when
we rerun the when we replay the program
it is executing in exactly the same way
as it did before
writes deterministic replay and that's
not always the case because you have you
have callbacks to the server and
math.random and things like that and so
while the program is running originally
you also have to store all these sources
of non-determinism so that's when you
play it back you can you can fill them
in and make sure that it runs in the
same way again
and so that adds a little bit of
overhead to but still it's much much
less than the full execution trace so it
takes a little bit of bookkeeping and
it's kind of hard to do but luckily
people have done this for us there's a
project for WebKit called time-lapse
it's an academic project and it has been
done a couple of years ago so I don't
know it's exact state status for now but
it doesn't have a lot of overheads and
it allows you to do this well basically
with any
visualization if you come up with right
because a system like this is
independent of the of the particular
visualization or instrumentation Li
thank you ads so now that we've seen
like tools like this it's it was still a
pretty contrived example in the
beginning and this was an educational
environment that was also pretty limited
what about real practical tools right
and there are some out there for various
programming languages not really for the
web unfortunately so a couple of months
ago I started in my spare time just
playing around with one of them and it's
actually integrated with the code base
for the company of the company that I
work for so I'll give you a quick demo
of what something like that would look
like so here's my company website look
running on my local machine just a quick
word about my company I work at this
company called brigades and we're trying
to re-engage citizens in the political
process and make it easy for them to
take a collective action so this is
their homepage and if you notice there's
this little bar at the bottom here then
we try to zoom in a little bit so
there's this bar here and this bar is
just a a representation of the execution
trades and if I click it you can see all
the events that happen in the system
right that that happened that happened
on my on the website and they're laid
out from left to right in the same way
as in the educational programming
environment chronologically and then I
used the vertical space to represent the
stack depth right so every time a
function is called we got one level deep
deeper and then when when it returns we
go up again and so you kind of kind of
explore what's happening here right and
I collapse certain certain branches of
the tree so that you don't have as of
the graph so that you don't see
everything at once so if we see
something interesting here like I think
initialization of the page happens here
like we can drill drill deeper right and
see see what's going on here
can you see this I'm just show it like
this so you can just go through
everything that happens right I mean
there's there's no point where we have
to call a debugger statement and we can
only move forward and then if you skip
over something like you can't go back
you have to rerun the program again and
just say oh this is this might be
interesting right and every time a
function is called you may notice here
that we all said that I also print and
locked the arguments to this function
like you can kind of see what's
happening and then there's also this
representation here of things in this
file that are happening around the same
lines so if I hover over this one and up
here you can see the corresponding
events in the execution trace they're
being highlighted right and just an
example of how you can use something
like this to understand the program if I
scroll down you can see that's that's
that the bar becomes larger and
something happens at the top of the
screen right so let me actually show
this on the team page I think it's a
little a little clearer there so if we
scroll down this bar to top dogs matthan
if I do that it goes away again and we
can actually see this very clearly in
the execution tray so here you see all
the events being called whenever I
scroll and then here suddenly something
happens right that we see a different
pattern and we immediately recognize
this and I can drill drill down and see
oh well we're actually rerender in the
dockable component so that's what's
going on there it's still all pretty
experimental oh yeah that's another
feature I can search for things here so
I'm on the team page here so if I search
for team I can find out where had the
team pages initially being rendered and
it's somewhere here so here the team
page is being rendered and all sorts of
stuff is happening here right
so yeah this is this is in a very raw
form online if you're interested in like
hacking on this or like in in this about
this stuff in general come talk to me
afterwards but just to recap with HTML
and CSS we can really already see what
the program does but with JavaScript we
are blind essentially we try to see
using console logs and debugger
statements but we should really be
omniscient right we are in control of
our machines and tools to become a
missions are surprisingly easy to make
like I did this in 10 minutes and once
you have them you can scale them to
larger systems there are tools out there
even for even for the browser to do that
and you can actually like build a
practical tool like this in a couple of
weekends with a real codebase and this
kind of works
so you can find more background
information on this page I don't know
how much more time we have when it
wanders this session ends Oh 15 minutes
yeah so we have plenty of time for
questions are there any questions
oh sure oh actually let me do this like
this yeah so actually if you go to this
page the github pages it's linked there
too and there's all sorts of research
and other tools up there too yes yes so
the question is how does a functional
programming language like how would that
work with visualizing it like this right
that's actually a really good question I
think because with functional
programming languages at least in terms
of all the other checkpointing and
deterministic replay it's probably a lot
easier to do that it's also quite
interesting to to visualize that
actually if you go to my site like not
the strange loop one but just just to
heard just this just my homepage there's
actually a project where I do that as
well
I might link to it from here that might
be interesting too
yes
yes
yeah
yeah so I did use it as testing with
that with children from like ten ages 10
to 18 or something I believe yeah
and it's it's it's kind of hard to tell
that feature that particular feature was
not very discoverable but I found it
particularly useful when doing like
instruction when showing something to
people like oh this is this is what's
going on and I think I've seen like some
children use it with the other features
that I showed where you can move your
mouse over things and like things light
up it's really hard to see if they are
using that because people just move
their bow surrounded like stuff happens
they definitely use the scrubbing of
values and and that was I think helpful
but yeah it's it was really hard to tell
if if they were using those features I
think in general like that the course
worked pretty well but then again I also
like make the exercises and such and so
I don't know what I can attribute to
through this editing environment I was I
can attribute to the actual exercises
that I came up with so yeah I don't know
exactly yes
oh yeah yes this is actually compatible
with reactor uploading because we use
that in our code base as well we don't
use the Redux system a redox system
would be very like that would integrate
with something like this very nicely I
would imagine yeah so I think that
there's like there's obviously like a
lot of crossover also with the
functional programming language there
are like the entire languages that's
like elements that's right that's that
this would work I think very very nicely
with yes
yeah and so the question is how does
this like work with unit testing does it
replace unit testing or does it go
alongside with them this I don't think
this would really replace unit testing
because like unit testing gives you
certain guarantees of how your program
executes and this just gives you
insights so you don't necessarily if you
change something notice that your
program actually behaves like an
incorrect way very easily but I have
fans that's when trying to debug a unit
test like it's the same as when trying
to debug like an actual problem in the
application that it's pretty helpful
like all this stuff also just runs in in
our Jasmin specs and I've used it like
that a couple of times yes
this is an excellent question because I
meant to say something about that but I
forgot so the question is have I
actually noticed an improvement in
developer productivity when using this
and the answer is not yet but I've only
been working on this like for for like
two months or something so the way that
it has gone so far is that I try to use
it as sometimes it was useful but
sometimes I I'm like oh [ __ ] I need I
need more data or like I did a search
function or I need this or need that and
I would write that down and in the
weekends I would make it that like the
next week I would I would try something
together like make notes of everything
that's that I read it to best at that
time yeah so I'm not quite sure yet I
hope it does like the academic research
that people have done into tools like
this suggests that it might but I don't
know yet no more questions
thanks a lot